[Musique]
ok
nous
les rails
oh my god
cayrol
salue tous bien bossé je suis une nana
qui fait de la musique je sente
attendent une pianiste je suis dispo
voir si non moi c'est moi ça va parce
que je suis je suis sold out ça n'a pas
de sens mais je n'ai pas par contre j'ai
j'ai texas oui j'ai sexe ass ouais mais
là par contre je pense que ça peut être
vraiment choquée par ce projet je parle
pas anglais - par contre
et c'est justement c'est justement
l'idée c'est super ça m'agace pas cette
offre merci julien si bien après ça lui
fait un
[Rires]
[Musique]
bon tour à tous c'est marine le pen
retrouvez-moi désormais sur pickton
maman ni qu'est ce que tu fais bacha tip
top j'étais pas au courant de ça non
mais attends qu est ce que tu fais
maintenant tu filmes pas à la 90e finale
face à monaco au rôle elle alors
au québec c'est bon t'es prêt oui ok
voilà bien j'ai vu sa sortie toc ok tu
vas devoir reconnaître le bruitage que
je fais d'accord ça va ok écoute
c'est un briquet c'est bien mais c'est
bien je suis chaud maintenant à tanger
juste ils étaient quelque chose dont je
post à main ici pour voir ce fait prêts
non quoi quoi allez les gars
ça fait quoi là cette classe en
[Musique]
jeu
élection sur les lèvres
n'arrive pas trop rigoler en fait ça
fait rêver ça va
bonjour aide quoi
c'est quoi ça
ne fait pas beaucoup de vent je veux pas
pourquoi c'est quoi dit
non